it resembles the blob from science
fiction stories but it's very real
these gel-like sheets of
disease-carrying mucus are spreading
across portions of the Mediterranean and
Adriatic see where this video was taken
this stringy mess is known as marine
usage they're visible on the surface of
the water as well creating a sudsy look
in the sea it's not one organism but a
congregation of organic matter joined
together the Musil age begins as a
cluster of mostly microscopic dead and
living matter and over time picks up
others looking for food or safety only
some of the animals are visible to the
human eye such as small shrimp and
crustaceans these blobs have been known
to exist at least since 1729 but a
recent study found a link between usage
outbreaks and warmer sea temperatures
study leader Roberto Donna Varro from
the Polytechnic University of marcaine
in Italy says there's concern because
the blobs attract bacteria and viruses
including a coli that would make the
blobs harmful to swimmers and an e.coli
presence can force closure of beaches
the bacteria can be deadly to fish and
other living organisms in the water and
the noxious mass also traps animals
coating their gills and suffocating them
Donna Varro says the Musil ages are
largest in the summer months his study
found that the number of Mew cyllage
outbreaks increased almost exponentially
in the last 20 years in the
Mediterranean he cautions that it's a
good example of what can happen if
climate warming continues the biggest
blobs can sink to the seafloor acting
like a blanket and smothering life at
the bottom
you
[Music]